our next speaker will be constant
self-described data geek yeah works with
machine learning dr. which is a French
company and he's been doing machine
learning for several years already so is
it better
cool thanks well thank you thank you for
introducing me thank you all for being
here so I'm here today to speak about
future importance and then symbol
methods because it's something that came
across my job she a month ago oddly at
least a year ago but before talking
about this I'd like to first introduce
myself if I can go to the next slide
which is not sure
so as prevention previously mentioned
directly working on octave technology
which is a French consulting cabinet in
digital transformation we all divided
into tribes and I'm part of the big data
analytics tribe so it's just a team of
20 or so people so what does it mean it
means that I'm mainly trying to generate
value out of data for my customers so
what is actually value it can be
financial value so just cut down on cost
reduction but it also can be business
value to understand process for example
why a machine is going to fail and when
it is going to fail so the typical
problems I'm working on Archer and Isis
basically for insurance predictive
maintenance in the industry and also
forecast predictions revenue revenue
prediction sorry revenue forecasts
before that I was working in data 61 the
former NICTA which stands for nicely the
National ICT in Australia so that might
explain a bit of my weird accent I'm
sorry about that it was based in Sydney
and it was the machine in a name
research group on my spare time
also like to play rugby and the guitar
but hopefully not at the same time
because it will not be good marriage and
I will also spend a lot of time on
cattle competitions or cattle like
competitions and cattle forums because
as far as I am concerned I think that
the state of the art of data science
nowadays and it's really really
interesting to read every every threads
the key that you can find there so it's
kind of weird because I have like an
echo or something
do you know it's okay cool cool so
actually it was thanks Chicago that I
went into the problem it was a
competition a year ago I think it was
hosted by Telstra the Australian
telecommunication operator and the goal
of the competition was a multi-class
classification of failure in the network
so it was pretty simple it was it was a
small data set and the key to the
competition was feature engineering
because data was completely anonymized
so I was trying to my best to design new
Bibles because I thought were clever and
the feature importance to always I was
using at the time was telling me that
the new features I design were used by
the model but my performances would not
change it was kind of disappointing and
frustrating because I was kind of stuck
in this loop trying to find something
clever and with the tool telling me that
it was being used but my performances
women would not change so I started to
get interesting to future importance at
the time and unfortunately I didn't win
the competition because there was a leak
actually and I couldn't find it
but I did win something because that's
the first moment I tried to understand
what was going on with feature
importance assessment and metrics so
here's an outline of how I want to
present my my thoughts and work on the
subject so because I was I am using a
lot of example techniques and mainly
random forests and the gradient boosting
that Travis mentioned before so I just
want to make a quick reminder
of those techniques and the state of the
auto feature importance and show you
through an example
another gaggle competition that the
future importance methods nowadays are
not relevant unfortunately then because
I really like gradient boosting and
especially extra boost we're going to go
into the implementation and the
algorithm itself to try to understand
how it works and design a good metric
and once the further because future
importance is about all the model
I was wondering before if it's possible
to get a point feature importance namely
is it possible to get for one prediction
one data point which feature is used for
this prediction and how much because it
would be the Holy Grail right and
because it's not a finished work there
are a lot of limits and also ways
forward that I want to share with you
guys to see what you think about it and
a couple of other slides because I think
you will have plenty of questions so
let's get right through it
future importance and in similar methods
what is an example method well it's all
what it always works the same way you
have a weak learner and you aggregate
them a weak learner basically is a
really poor predictor by itself if you
use it alone you don't have good
predictions at all but if you combine it
with several others you get something
impressively robust and reliable so when
you use in symbols techniques you have
always two questions to wonder the first
one is what is the weak learner I want
to use so in my case there are decision
trees because they're quite handy but
you can also use in a regression if you
want never seen it especially in
competitions but it works and the second
one is the way you want to aggregate
your weak learners and actually the
differences between and simple
techniques lay in the way you aggregate
individual learners the difference
between random forests election boost is
actually the way your aggregated so this
curve here is a fundamental result that
was found by Travelocity who's a great
researcher machine learning in
statistical inference and he showed I
think it was thanks to adaboost that is
another and simple method the a
collection of 30 tree stone
trés namely was one split thus better
that a 244 note decision tree below that
it's way worse regarding the test error
of course so you just measure that the
error you make on a test set and below
this threshold of 30 it's way worse so
you can see that you're weak learners
are not good by themselves but if you
combine them a lot and I mean a lot it's
400 trees it's much much better than
just a huge decision tree that is
probably the best so it's quite of
interesting that to realize that
actually by combining weak
your honour's you have better results
than a huge machinery alright so I
mentioned earlier that I'm gonna use as
weak learners decision tree so you can
see one here and it's pretty simple to
understand it's just succession of
splits and that's a chess play you're
gonna choose you're gonna have a viable
and compare it to your threshold and if
you are below the start threshold you're
gonna go a certain path and above you're
gonna go another pass all the way down
to the leaf and in the leaf there's a
school but well go deeper on that later
on because it's a bit difficult to
understand just like this and actually
future importance is just quantifying
the effect of a feature on the
prediction itself all right making
possible to measure the importance of
the feature on this prediction so what
is better than an example to show it to
you
mentioned earlier that I'm a kegel
addict so I'm gonna take another Carroll
competition which is the Santander
customer satisfaction it's quite a
simple problem because it's a binary
classification you need to didn't mind
if a customer is going to be happy or
not so happy is class 0 and Happiness
class 1 and the data set is pretty small
I think it was it's 370 features and
tens of thousands of lines so we've way
below the Big Data Holden was talking
about earlier and it's a bit like the
Telstra competition it's off it's just a
small data set that allows you to play
so I just loaded the raw variables the
data and run an extra boost binary
classification and so I took this
evaluation set outside from the tread
set and I get a score across body gate
score so my my evaluation said is
relevant
comparing the distribution of the target
and I get this rock a UC school it does
it everyone understands what it means
it's just I really under the curve all
right so it's pretty much a good score
because the clues are your two one the
better you are so I'm pretty good I have
my model it's pretty good it has good
predictive power and I want to compute
you two important so it's just a bunch
of trees right so you can go across all
of your trees and count every time you
use a feature and divide it by all the
splits right so I call it cumulative sum
of the future and I get this curve on
the right and guess what this is exactly
what s Kalyan provides you with when you
make future importance they just count
every time you use a feature and divide
it by the Sun it's very interesting you
can see this is the top the top 10 best
contributors sorry for the Polish
problem and some of them are some of
them sorry are really really important
and the thing is you can see here or
maybe not but I'm telling you that this
one is the ID and it's kind of weird to
think that the target is related to the
ID because it's actually just a unique
identifier for the form for the data
point so either it means that this
variable is created to the target
variable so the identification is not
good all there is a problem with this
assessment and in order to quantify that
I ran this small experiment I wanted to
use complete random variable that has no
link and no predictive power toward the
target and see how it goes so in order
to do that I just created a random noise
samples from uniformly distributed
variable between 0 and 1 but actually
the interval is not important just
something purely uniform and not some
Gaussian noise that you can find
anywhere and I run the algorithm again
so I
make a performance measure and actually
it's the same which is quite good
because I didn't break anything else so
I should have the same performance
because if the algorithm is good and
robust I should have the same prediction
which is the case but then I make the
feature importance computation according
to the same the same method and guess
what here it's the noise and it's the
third most important contributor in this
problem so what does it mean is it idea
noise that are the most important
compared to all those variables designed
by the business side probably not
so the the way the future importance was
computed was wrong and completely not
robust and by wrong I mean not useful to
understand if the feature is useful for
the prediction itself and it's quite
understandable if you go back to the
very structure of a decision tree so
here's an example of a simple decision
tree you have X and X something that are
the variables of the problem black
figures for the class photo blown sorry
sorry the negative class and red figures
for the positive class right so tries to
separate all this all these occurrences
to make sure that you have leaves
represented by one class or another
that's the computation of the score here
so if you can look at the first plate of
a at the top of the of the tree X for
below three huh well you can see that
it's pretty good for the positive class
because it splits it into into two good
groups small groups on the right side
and big groups on the left it's not that
good for the negative class all right
but still it deals with a lot of
occurrences in the problem because it
takes all the data points and I sign a
pass to each of them so does it have the
same influence in the in the prediction
than the x8 you can see here on this
third split or not I don't think so
because even if this XA here has a good
splitting strategy especially for the
negative class it deals with with fewer
occurrences so it would wouldn't be fair
to consider it comparable to the X for
the beginning and another example is the
X
that you can see on the second split the
bullet on the left side yeah it's also
pretty good to predict the negative
class here because if you land in this
leaf you're pretty sure that you're
gonna be a negative class right but it's
not that good if you don't learn in that
in that one but still it has some power
to make a discrimination in your data
much more than this one here and it's
still the same variable so is that fair
to clone it twice for the same tree with
the same way I don't think so so in
order to design something more
meaningful it's going to be a bit
painful I guess but we need to go to the
really core of gradient boosting itself
and this is what you have so what you're
looking at is not just a bunch of lines
of text it's just a part of the first
three of the problem I have before okay
so this is the same the first line over
there is the feature you/yous Saldivar
30 I don't know what it is yes am i
below the threshold 95 so then I go to
one and if I'm not I go to two and then
you have missing variables so this is
examples here the implementation it
deals with the missing variables that
way it assign your path according to the
distribution and you have two really
interesting stats after that again and a
cover so the gain is pretty interesting
- pretty easy to understand here we're
dealing with classification it's just a
game regarding the criterion you use to
make the split so here I was using
Anthropy so it's just a gain in Anthropy
but if you use a Gini criterion it's
gonna be increasing in the pureness of
your of your of YouTube's subsequent
leaves the cover is a bit more difficult
to understand it is actually the action
of the cost function evaluated on all
the points concerned by displays why is
it important for extra boost
well the action is the derivative of the
gradient and gradient boosting is all
about creating why
because the tree at the iteration and
plus one is going to learn on the
gradient of the errors of the tree at
the iteration M it's a bit difficult to
understand but it's how it works so this
figure here is both an information of
the size of the people you are dealing
with and also the mistakes you make so
is that clear so far it's not that
important to understand how exhibits
work or how gradient boosting itself
work but if it's really interesting to
see that you have actually this gained
valuable I was talking about before so
if I use it to compare with the results
that I had earlier and I hope it's gonna
work yes it does this is the cumulative
gain regarding all the variables so it's
not just not counting the occurrences
but also multiplying by the gain it
provides at each split and you can see
that we have two winners here so
Saldivar 30 and valve 15 whereas here
noise and ID are competing in the tale
and there's no competition here my
signal my predictive signal is here and
noise an idea I'll just trying to do
something and so be painful to watch
right but it's interesting to see that
it's at the end of iterations that they
start to summer right so just gonna wait
a bit to make sure that it's stable but
noise an ID having the same behavior
here so maybe it means that ID is also
kind of a noise for my problem so you
can see that it's pretty set that those
variables here are useful in terms of
gains and those are not go outside the
loop and explain it a bit further I
mentioned that they were used at the end
of the iterations and you can see it
here on this slide two strong pieces of
information the first one is the graph
that you have above this is just the
cumulative sum of use with respect to
the iteration and you can see that the
killer feature sold over 30 is being
used at the big
of deteriorations whereas the noise is
used mainly at the end so remember what
I said about gradient boosting is just
learning on the mistakes of the previous
trees so if you're being used at the end
you are being used at the smallest
errors of the of the of the model itself
so it's a bit dangerous to have this
kind of interpretation but still we can
think that most of the predictive power
is used by the best by side over 30 a
noise is just what we call small signals
the small stuff that makes the
difference in the composition it makes
you win like point one percent on your
prediction the second information on
this slide is also really important and
this is this table the table here is
just the depth of the different trees I
have in my model sorry can you say sorry
so what is that aid because it's a
parameter of my of my algorithm I said
the maximum depth to be a because it's
some it's a sound technique to make sure
that you don't have a fit but you can
have trees with a much lower depth
alright so the second line is just among
all the trees of the different depth how
many what's the percentage of them using
the variable noise and you can see that
most of it is used in large trees and
not small trees okay the third line is
among the trees using using the noise
variable where is it used and is it
using the second part of the tree so
relatively at the end of the tree and
most of the time it's the case so you
can say that noise is mainly using huge
trees at the end of the trees so if you
remember the small tree I design earlier
it means that if there's with few
occurrences and that's quite sound
because it means that it doesn't have
any predictive power at all so given
those stats is it possible to design a
new metric for sorry for future
importance well then I propose this one
this is just a few reporters for one
tree is just again it provides divided
by the
the number of deterioration they noted
booster him squared and you sum it
across all the trees why is that because
it works actually
so using this feat this metric here I
make my future comparison here so in red
is the just the cumulative sum and green
is the custom son I make and you can see
that I both idea noise are not used but
actually they are in the top 10 and
noise is ranked ninth with this method
so it's like still it's used so maybe it
means that it's still not robust enough
well guess what I run the algorithm
again with the eight variables above
noise and have the same performances so
it means that all right I lost the small
signals but the main power of the
prediction are having mice in my signals
are in these eight variables so it's
really interesting because with this run
with the advisor Bo's I have a training
error and a test error during the
learning session equivalent so it means
that I'm really less likely to other fit
but still there's a there's a point that
was bothering me still a global future
importance right it's it's all about the
model itself but maybe I'm more
interested in the points that are
predicted to one for us they should be
pretty into zero which is a false
positive or maybe the other way around
maybe I want to see the false negative
predictions so is it possible to have a
point-to-point feature importance and I
try to find something that I'm going to
show you now so if we go back to the
example before and you use a new data
point X well you can see that it depends
on the on the value of the variables in
X right the occurrences but it's going
to follow only one path in each tree
right and for each tree is going to be
associated to only one score and the
rest of them are not used so actually
does it make any sense to say industry
the viable
three over there is useful for my
prediction I don't think so on the other
hand X 4 X 5 X 2 are useful because it
leads me to the school associated so huh
how do i how do i quantify it how do I
actually use it for prediction oh sorry
just one point before why is it
important to go to a point to point
prediction well it's where become the
consultant again because my client asked
me to do it because like literally it's
like working for an insurance company
someone is going to tell me well you
need to predict me if someone is going
to churn yeah sure eighteen eighty nine
percent of the time he's gonna churn why
because the model is say so try stated
earlier in this morning talking about
black boxes and stuff what people don't
like black boxes they need to trust the
prediction itself and if you're not able
to have it well it's useless and they're
gonna tell you yeah that's nice but I'm
not going to sell it to my clients or my
customers so the real question here is
how do we can quantify it because you
can't say yeah it's a bit of X 4 X 5 but
I don't know why well even if it's a bit
conservative bit with what I said before
regarding the cumulative sum because we
are on the point ask a granularity level
it's kind of it kind of makes sense to
say that this score here 5:34 associated
to this point is one-third of X for
one-third of X 5 and what one-third of X
2 because there's no depth anymore
there's just one path right there's no
size effect so this is the the
hypothesis I took in order to assess it
and this is just for one tree so if I
want it for all the features in my trees
in all of my trees in my forest I'll
just sum it up and the weight is just
the number of features that are used in
each tree and the total weight
is the school that you have here so
normally you know like well he's keep
talking about the schools and stuff but
I don't mind where is the prediction in
that I mean 534 is not a probability
right so what is the link between the
scores and the probability well it's
pretty straight forward because actually
all the scores you have some up to a
certain value denoted here f of X right
and this call is going to be used by
your model to give you your prediction
and it depends on the problem so here
this is a classification a binary
classification so it's going to be input
in in a sigmoid function so just take a
moment just to let it sink in we learn
something on the mistakes of previous
trees giving you score so you learn on
the gradient of the error you sum it up
you pass it through a sigmoid function
and it gives you something rubbish I
mean it took me at least a year to
accept it without understanding it
doesn't make any sense at first but it's
pretty robust right
and since we're able to link the feature
to the score well you can link it to the
sigmoid function right because if you're
negative gonna be predicted zero the
probability to be zero is gonna be high
right on the other right if you're
positive you're going to have a
probability of being one that is high
right so you can rank your variables
according to the impact the weight they
give to the sign of your prediction and
why is it interesting well because of
residual interpretations mentioned
earlier that sometimes your algorithm is
going to be wrong all models are wrong
some some are useful but for example if
you take if you take the 10 most false
positive occurrences'
meaning that you predicted that your
customer is going to be unhappy plus 1
but actually is quite happy what is the
cost of that well it depends on the
build of the business right but it might
be really cost for because if it's
someone you need to
to call or something if I spend money to
make sure that the person is not going
to churn for example whereas apparently
he wouldn't churn so it's it might be
useful to understand why you predicted
that that point to be one so I took
those 10 points right so the high
problem not a high probability of being
zero I make the point featuring
importance and for each point I take the
top five contributors toward a positive
value right if you remember the sigmoid
function the points that make it close
to the class one and the results are
quite interesting because for four of
the ten data points two variables come
out and the southern media 583 I'm sorry
it's ghetto and var 3 and actually they
are not the killer features that we had
before so well plainly into small
signals here those variables are
actually really meaningful for those
thing ten points or at least support
them and it's because of them that they
are wrongly predicted so it's a lead for
Intel investigation but there is a major
drawback here I don't tell you why this
variable make this prediction there is
not the threshold associated I'm not
sure that maybe for the first point is
the threshold for three it's going to be
for example 10 and for another point
it's going to be minus 8 I don't know
it's just a lead for in this
investigation and then you go back to
your data look if you have a glitch look
at if you have noise if your acquisition
process is wrong now I think it's quite
funny huh but there's one point I did
not mention and it's quite quite
important and this this is probably the
biggest limit of this of this approach
and this one is a correlated variable if
if you've been doing machine learning
for the past few years you probably
realized that machine learning is all
about correlation and of causality and
it's a huge drawback nowadays so of
course your variables are going to be
record ated because they describe the
same problem for example in the current
problem
it's as available you can have the total
time spent on the hotline and the number
of course those two variables are
connected by correlated highly correct
correlated so I made a small experiment
with correlated variables and I took
four was 450 because it was easier to
write and I created a correlated
variables of are 15 correlated to 95
percent Pearson correlation coefficient
sorry and if I run the future importance
well funny thing is it's just considered
like a noise with the first assessment
so it's used but also with the second
assessment so what happens in here the
predictive power is a bit of diluted
right it's being used if the algorithm
uses either this one or this one
and we don't know which is which but
actually the actual the the meaningful
signal behind it is the same okay so the
thing is a 95% correlated variable in
your dataset is really not likely to
happen but still we're talking about a
general a huge scale on the other models
itself but if you go to the point
feature prediction you don't know maybe
50 percent correlation is enough maybe
30 I don't know and that's quite
concerning if you if that's something
that you can you need to have in mind if
you use such tools and the other huge
drawback we had is that interpretation
is not a miracle in the sense that
prediction is the prediction and it
won't be prescription we my company we
had this in the same assessment with
random forests it was really really good
and for example it was for predictive
maintenance in industry and we noted a
few variables that we had leverage the
leverage sorry on and the client said
well you tell me it's because of x4 if I
put X for 2-3 instead of five for this
data point it's going to be predicted
non faulty right
and actually you are you are being a bit
of a wizard when you do that because
you're creating a new data point that
you didn't see in your training session
and you're not in the nominal behavior
anymore so maybe if the spawn appears on
naturally speaking in some sense it's
going to be predicted as 40 and not an
40 and you don't know that so I think
the conclusion is there will always be a
compromise between predictive power and
interpretability
and my boss viana made a good a good
presentation of it fortunately it's in
French but it's on YouTube and he called
it the Heisenberg star M for machine
learning it's kind it's kind of kind of
true actually but still even if it's not
achievable I think those tools are
pretty interesting and the few few
thoughts I have for the next steps is
that I would like to adapt it on
multi-class classification so for extra
boost how is it handled well it's just
one versus all so you have number of
iteration times number of classes trees
so how do you handle it with with this
problem for regression is a bit
different because the criterion you use
for you split is not the same it's about
the variance it's not about entropy even
if it's kind of related but the cause of
regression are inherently different
because it's just the mean of the
variables that end in the leaves so it's
something I need you to watch and
probably the fourth point is the one
that interests me most because something
that I had in one of my missions before
is the influence of the cost function
itself because you can choose to have
for example an absolute error as a cost
function or square error as a cost
function to learn to tea to train your
model right well what's it what's the
influence of it because for example the
ma PE is going to is going to to flatten
your predictions to a main viable to
Amin Amin level so is there any
explanation that I can have with feature
exponet with the future importance and
the last point had was does it make any
sense to get the thresholds with with
the the point-to-point future prediction
because maybe it's no use at all so
these are all the thoughts ahead and I
think it's pretty much it for this
presentation so thank you for attention
I think we have plenty of time for the
questions
[Applause]
because if you don't have food oh this
one's for you hi thanks for a nice
presentation in your definition of the
point score I believe you called it
could you go back to the definition of
the point two point score so point of
this one yeah so um how do you account
for the fact that variables at a higher
level on the tree are likely to be part
of more paths than variables at a lower
level
well since it's on a point level there
is no up and below there's just one path
right so this point I mean if you don't
look at the rest of the tree for this
point if the last plate is the first one
it's the same we don't care actually
because it's just for one point you seem
to disagree
yep
well I'm sure forget it because it's
always beyond one point right this is
the point of one future prediction for
one point and afterwards when I was
using it for residual in our analysis
the 10 points had the 10 path general
path in the trees so it's generalizable
in the sense that each time it's just
like you take all the paths and just put
them in the way you want because it's
gonna be just the path for the point I'm
not sure if it's yeah yeah we can
discuss it later if you want
yeah thank you it seems it's very
important it's well I'm usually not so
happy with feature importance of random
force for example
yeah I use a linear one because then you
can say something about is it like
positive or negative right sure but yeah
it seems really good when you when you
when you can remove this kind of noise
it's what the default random forest in
scikit-learn for example would do this
wrongly is that what you were saying I'm
not saying it's wrong it's wrong to call
it feature importance actually so the
question was noise cancellation feature
importance is not built in in psychic
learn for example future importance I
think it's a bit of a mistake of calling
in future importance because actually if
you go back if you fall for example for
this tree here if you have an infinite
depth you will use every feature and at
the end of the tree you're gonna split
just for couple of occurrences and it
has no predictive power at all because
if you have an infinite range you're
really likely to overfit that's the
example of the beginning of Travelocity
but you're quoted random forest so it's
for the depth but also the numbers of
trees and random forest does another
thing so you can possibly use an
infinite number of trees so if you use
just cumulative sum of using of features
as a future importance metric well
you're gonna have them all so it's not
relevant even though the last trees
aren't useful at all and doesn't provide
any any any information on the
prediction itself so I think it's a bit
yeah it's been harsh too cold to say
it's it's wrong I know but at least for
my problem that I have with the Carroll
competition it was not useful at all
follow-up question yeah sure did you I
mean so did you compare your algorithm
compared to any comparisons course if
you would just use like the default and
differences the algorithm you implement
your own kind of scoring function so did
you compare that to just using the
out-of-the-box kind of cycle yeah yeah
well actually that some oh you mean in a
competition and with a signal not
actually no because the thing is
competitions are not the real world
right so you're always trying to find
the small signals and sometimes you're
actually learning the simple process of
the leaderboard so it's not really
useful at all and actually this is a
good question because when I said that
the noise is removed and that's up eight
contributors have the same performances
well actually it's a bit more important
like in the real world because it means
that you're using the most signals with
with not additional features that
doesn't count right so the thing is in
competition it's pretty difficult to do
it because your for example for the AUC
for the signal for this competition was
like another fifth digit after after the
comma so anything matters and you can
like skywalk on the little ball if you
use everything so no I didn't test it on
a competition yet probably had a bull
talking about the the real world beyond
the competitions it is the challenge of
convincing a client that okay like you
have to share the data with me then you
have to work with the person to get the
right question that you can be able to
answer you run the whole model and then
you come with with with that output you
are comfortable with the output then for
me the biggest challenge is to be able
to communicate it and to make it
actionable within within the business so
what's your advice to communicate it to
the business owner I'm convinced that
persona has to change his business in a
different way based on on this model so
let me rephrase the question to make
sure that I understood I'm really
confident in my algorithm and it tells
me that my customer needs to change the
business in some sense and how how do i
how do I tell him right yeah yeah what
would be the best way to communicate
that well we tried it actually I
mentioned that we did it for random
forests and these are the slides I was
saving so this is a small small tool
that we call the next best action okay
so this is for random forest I think it
was for faulty detection okay
and so a binary classification and you
have just as the influence towards the
class and you can pick all the variables
that you have leverage on and you can
compute a new a new probability if you
change those variables so with this
model we can tell him well if you follow
the entire model you will have this
prediction so it's a bit graphic but
remember what I said prescription is not
achievable and actually the business
side is the real owner of the business
and I can tell the business side well
you need to change it because they've
been doing this this for the past 50
years or so so the actual message I
would have would be please remain in the
room business site that become data
scientists because it would change the
way you you do your business but I
starts I'm concerned I don't have the
right to tell anyone
well you need to change it I just tried
to open the eyes I don't know if you can
make sense
and in addition business side is always
a good source for signals because most
of the time is just like you're in the
middle of something you don't understand
and at the end the really cool guy a
really exciting coal guy from the
business that's going to tell you well
this is because of this temperature or
this is because of this pressure over
there and then your motto just
skyrockets regarding the regarding the
metrics so I'm just what data science is
just a tool
this time okay given that the current
implementation of how feature importance
in cycle learn is not really optimal to
getting the real importance have you
thought about contributing your
implementation to cycle learn to like be
able to choose say okay instead of the
way this one with Jesus or one which can
be more useful for business problems the
thing is the code at least for every
boost because it's the implementation I
use the most and maybe I'll find
something but of course I don't mean to
be rude to them they've been doing a
great job and Travis mentioned it
earlier today it's really useful what
they've done the thing is some of the
tools can be tunable so yeah I think
it's but it's gonna be able to been
sourced someday
but if there are no more questions let's
thumb that speaker again
[Applause]